looking for someone oled  [Applause]  kelly olynyk has won it for detroit  reviewing to make sure the shot is  timely it's all over  the  hornets 15-game winning streak against  detroit is all over  the hornets get knocked out they get  ko'd  by kelly only had to review the basket  counts  and that's what happened folks when you  let a team hang around  the olynyk  he had 15 in the fourth  and his biggest two of the night right  there  tough away  so the hornets lose  on a sunday night against  detroit  their 15-game winning streak against the  pistons is all over  and now the hornets will have to head to  the airport hop on a plane and take on  the world champion milwaukee bucks